- [Al Michaels:] And they start
with a horrible snap.
And the Browns
wind up with a touchdown!
- We're not just a bunch
of "gray faces" anymore!
- Who can't win a playoff game?!
- [Fan:] Lamar!
Ohh! Ohh! Ohh! Ahh!
- [Stefon Diggs:] That's one, baby! Ahh!
- Welcome
to the playoffs, baby.
- Hey, these games
ain't for everybody!
These games for the elite!
- Just give all you got!
- [Announcer:] Today in Buffalo,
it's the 11-5 Colts
and the 13-3 Bills
in the AFC Wild Card Game.
- [Darius Leonard:]
Let’s go! Yeah! Yeah!
- [Commentator:] One of
the big stories today,
the return of the Bills fans,
6,700 of them, anyway.
- [Jordan Poyer:] Oh, I can play catch
with the best!
- [Singing:] Let's go, Buffalo.
Let's go, Buffalo.
- [Josh Allen:]
Hey, one job: that’s win.
- "Win" on three. One, two, three.
- [Together:] Win!
- Go, Bills!
- [Announcer:]
It's the 12-4 Seahawks
hosting the 10-6
Los Angeles Rams
on Super Wild Card Weekend.
- [Russell Wilson:] Beautiful day to play ball.
- [Robert Woods:] Y'all ready for showtime?
- [Aaron Donald:]
Let's be great! Let's be great!
- Let's go get it done. Come on.
Championship mindset.
Championship mindset. One play
at a time. Let's go dominate.
- [Announcer:]
The GOAT Tom Brady will make
his 43rd appearance
in a playoff game.
- TAMPA!
- [Terry McLaurin:] Let's go, brother.
Let's have a good day, man.
I believe in you, bro.
- [Announcer:]
Taylor Heinicke comes in here.
It is a huge, huge task
ahead of him.
- Hey, we representin'
for my man Heinick-E! Heinick-E!
- [Announcer:] Ravens get set
to take on the Tennessee Titans.
This is a rematch
from last year's playoff loss.
- [Calais Campbell:] Yeah, baby! Let's go!
- Caw! Caw!
- [Pernell McPhee:] I ain't ready to go home!
Ain't nothin' to be said!
I ain't ready to go home!
- We all we got. We all we need.
Let's go. "Titans" on three.
One, two, three.
- [Together:] Titans!
- [Akiem Hicks:] This is your chapter.
This is us right now.
Nothing else in the past matters
but this moment.
- All right, everybody. We got
Bear playoff football today.
Mitch, these are the kind
of games you play for.
Win or go home.
- [Tony Romo:]
Really think Drew Brees knows
this is one of the best shots
to win a Super Bowl.
- [Drew Brees:]
Let's go, baby! Get in here!
Hey, play inspired!
Play inspired!
For everything we've been
through together this year!
- "Win" on three! One, two, three!
- Win!
- Man, you know what time it is.
Playoff football, in Pittsburgh.
Prime time.
It don't get no better, man.
- I've been waiting
18 long years for this!
Go, Browns!
- [Myles Garrett:] Whatever you got tonight,
I got to have it!
I need it all!
- Might not be no tomorrow.
There might not be no tomorrow.
- [Mario Addison:] You know what time it is?
Time to party.
- Hut!
- [Announcer:]And the snap goes high over
the head of Big Ben.
All the way back to the one.
And they dive on the ball
and recover it for a touchdown!
Unbelievable start!
- [Fans cheering]
- 18 years
since our last playoffs.
A defensive touchdown
off a fumble.
I'm not getting off
this treadmill
for the rest of my life.
- [Fan:] Yeah! Get it! Whoo!
Yeah!
- That's what I'm talkin' about!
Let's go!
- [Garrett:] Let's go!
- I wonder if a playoff game's
ever started like that before.
- [Laughing] No.
- [Announcer:] Josh keeps it.
He's gonna try to run with it.
And now he's gonna throw it
into the end zone. It is caught!
Touchdown!
[Fans chanting "MVP!"]
- [Announcer:]
Jackson, deep drop.
Firing deep downfield.
Going for Boykin.
And it is intercepted!
- [Announcer:]
Dumps it over the middle.
It's picked off! Another
turnover by the Steelers!
- [Announcer:]
Throw the bubble. Picked!
Darious Williams jumped it!
- Oh, he's going!
- He's going! Go!
- Let's go! Pick-six, baby!
Yeah! Whoo!
- [Sean McVay:] Oh, my God!
- [Baker Mayfield:] Important for us to keep
our foot on the gas now.
We just do our job
each and every play.
- [Announcer:] Here comes Hunt.
He's gonna get to the 5.
And he's going in! Touchdown!
The Browns lead 28-nothing
in the first quarter!
- Yeahhh!
- [Wilson:] Let's go. Hey,
you about to go off.
You about to go off.
Can't wait to see it.
Let's go. Come on.
- [Announcer:]
A late blitzer coming.
Russ, gotta get rid of it.
Look out.
Now he's gonna throw.
- [Damontre Moore:] Yeah!
- [Announcer:] Metcalf makes the catch!
Holy catfish!
A perfect deep strike!
- Way to keep playing.
Good job, men.
Great job. Great job right
there. That's a great job.
- [Lamar Jackson:] We gotta go score.
- [Announcer:]
Pocket collapsing. He escapes.
On a magnificent scramble
and dash for the end zone.
- [Fan:] That's right.
That's what we talkin' ‘bout!
Easy money! Let's go!
Easy money!
- Yeah!
- [John Harbaugh:] Yeah! Yeah!
- Well, I'mma beat him
on that choice,
cuz I'mma take it
and whoop, whoop!
- [Announcer:] Josh firing deep
down near the end zone,
looking for Diggs. He's got it!
Touchdown! Touchdown, Buffalo!
- I told you. I told y'all.
I told y'all. I told y'all.
- [Announcer:] Heinicke
is running to the left side.
To the 5.
Diving for the end zone!
- [PA announcer:] Touchdown!
- [Man:] Heinick-E! Heinick-E!
♪♪♪
- [Announcer:]
On the flea flicker from
Patterson to Trubisky.
- Oh, he dropped it!
- And Wims dropped a touchdown
over the back.
- [Brees:] Hey, let's crank it up.
Great tempo now.
One play at a time.
Get open for me if you can.
- [Announcer:] Looking
for someone to throw to.
Under pressure.
He dumps it underneath.
Latavius Murray at the 5,
across the goal line!
Touchdown!
- Get in there! Yeah!
- [Players:] Yeah!
- [McVay:] Hey.
Crazy how it happened.
But you're gonna be great, man.
Let's go, buddy.
- [Jared Goff:] Hey, let's go, baby.
Let's go. Let's go.
- [Announcer:]
Goff lofts the ball, left side.
Robert Woods walks in!
- [Players cheering]
- [Announcer:] They're moving on.
- They can take
their hats and T-shirts to Cabo!
- The Seahawks lost to the Rams
in Round 1.
Tragic. Absolutely tragic.
- [Announcer:]
Two seconds to go. Mitch to throw.
Up in the air.
- [Jim Nantz:]
That is caught! Jimmy Graham!
Wow!
Brees is—and he's
just taking it right in.
- [Mitch Trubisky:] Good job, dude.
Good game, man.
Good luck. Best of luck.
- [Brees:] I hope I see you this
offseason, all right?
- Yeah.
- [Tom Brady:] Big drive, boys.
Come on. Big drive.
- Let's go, Tom.
- C’mon, let's take control.
♪♪♪
- [Announcer:] Godwin beat
the defender. A post route.
And it's another touchdown.
- Yeah!
- Bucs win!
- [Fan:] Say "Go, Bucs."
- Go, Bucs.
- [Bruce Arians:] Good job.
- [Brady:] Way to play, bro.
- [Chase Young:] I appreciate you.
- Good job. Keep it up.
- I need something from you, though.
- What you need?
- I need this off you.
- OK. I'll send it to you.
All right, man.
Good luck to you.
- Praying that God
is a Colts fan.
- [Poyer:] Hey, knock it down.
- [Announcer:] Four seconds left.
They get one play to make it.
- [Fans shouting]
- [Announcer:] Rivers going for all of it
down the right sideline.
The pass up in the air.
It is knocked down, incomplete!
- [Cheering]
- And the clock showed zero!
The Bills advance!
The Bills win it!
- Yeah! Ha ha! Whoo!
- [Announcer:] In the last
second, the Bills win it!
What a finish.
Unbelievable finish!
- [Diggs:] That's one, baby! Ahh!
- Doesn't change what
we gotta do. Let's go get it.
- [Mike Vrabel:] Do whatever you gotta do
to keep getting first downs.
- [Ryan Tannehill:] Yep.
- [Announcer:] Marcus Peters
drops into coverage.
- [Steve Levy:]
Tannehill steps and fires.
And it's intercepted!
- Ahh! Ha ha! Yeah!
Yee-yee-yee-yee-yee!
- [Harbaugh:] Yeah! Let’s go!
- [Announcer:] They're out there
stomping on the logo.
- The disrespect!
The disrespect!
Get outta here, fool!
- [Harbaugh:] You did it.
You said you’d do it, and you did it.
- I'm off to the store
because I need ice cream.
- Who can't win a playoff game?!
- Whoo!
- Who?! Who can't win one?
- [Fan:] Lamar! Lamar!
Ohh! Ohh! Ohh! Ahh!
- [Garrett:] A touchdown or a takeaway.
We gotta put 'em away!
- [Announcer:] We're gonna
go to the fourth quarter.
The Browns lead by 12.
Screen pass, right side.
Here comes Chubb.
He's going! He's going!
He's gone! Touchdown!
- [David Njoku:] It ain't impossible to get
another turnover right now.
- [Announcer:]
Throws it over the middle!
- Picked off.
- It's picked off!
Takitaki's got it!
Big Ben throws
his fourth interception!
- [Tae Davis:] You get one!
You get one! You get one!
All the Dawgs get one, baby!
- All the Takis back at the crib!
- Everybody back home, baby!
- How ‘bout those...
- Pittsburgh Steelers?!
[Both laughing]
- [Maurkice Pouncey:] Ah, man.
- [Ben Roethlisberger:] Oh, I feel worse for you than me.
I hate it, man.
- Same old Browns. Make sure you get that.
- You hear me?
- We the same old Browns. Remember that.
- You can TikTok
all the way to fishin', buddy.
You can fish all night long.
- We'll see you next week
in Kansas City!
- [Fan:] Front row!
Yeah! Whoo!
- [Fans laughing]
- Whoo!
- [Fan laughing]